是在孩子一岁整那个生日的时候，发现我的前夫一直在骗我啊，就是他关于他的家庭，他父母的工作，关于他的工作，关于他的收入，全部都是在欺骗我哦。就是他其实是一个啊，一无所有的人，但是他跟我给我说的是啊，他有婚前的房子啊，他有什么车啊，他有啊，年薪多少的收入啊，他父亲是年收入多少的这个做包工的这个人，但这些所有的都是骗我的。嗯，然后就是我结婚了嘛。结婚的时候，我爸我妈给我给了我当时是20个W，就是作为这个嫁妆现金，然后我没有花嘛，因为他当时骗我说他买了一套房没有装修，我爸我妈就说拿这钱回头就可以装修嘛，就是孩子一周岁的时候，因为我结婚，然后生活费。因为他每天都是不工作的，他跟我说他跟他爸出去到工程工程的那个工地现场，其实都是假的。然后她就是生了孩子以后，当时我们那个孩子生下来呛那个羊水住院，刚生下来，然后住ICU可能也花了不少钱，包括这个婚啊，结婚后一周一年，这个生活费，孩子的各种各的费用其实都在花我的那个嫁妆的钱。但是我不知道，他就偷偷的从我那个卡里全部划走了。然后到孩子一周岁的时候，我爸我妈又给了我一笔一笔钱，说给孩子这个一周纸。
生日吧，我拿着这些钱去我银行存的时候，我才发现我银行卡里的那个钱没了。然后就就是办这个分手的这个法律程序，因为他不愿意分手，拖了大概有半年。因为我父母希望呃给他一个所谓的浪子回头的机会啊，大概有半年的时间。然后在这半年的时间，就是我经历了一些他的朋友，他轮番的到我的单位去讨债，就说他问别人借了钱，说是我的孩子生病了啊，需要这个医药费，然后去要这个借这个钱，反正一个W，两个W，反正各种同学啊，他的朋友啊，就堵到我的单位门口。我单位是一个怎么说就算一个事业单位吧，他堵到我的单位门口就问我要钱，就是这个影响特别不好，然后，我就下决心走这个法律程序了。法律当时判的时候是每个月他给1000块钱生活费。但从法院判决到现在，我不停的在接各种网贷平台的电话。各种网贷平台非常的频繁给我发信息打电话，严重到就是影响我工作了。我在公众场就是工作的这个场合不停的在接到这种这种催债电话。嗯，我现在就是一直到今今天早上我还在收到这种短信息，我就非常的生气。因为我的孩子呢，今年9岁多，上了小学三年级，然后成绩不是很好，我今年就开始给他找各种这种辅导老师，可能就。
是大课对于我的孩子可能专注力不是很好，可能大课对于孩子的这个学习效果提升不是很好。我现在就给他报这个小小一点的课，但是费用可能就会很高。然后我就跟他协商，我说这个费用我不管是你出钱还是你父母出钱，但是这个孩子的费用因为我一个人现在承担不了了，我的工资覆盖不了这个孩子的这个学习费用了。我说我们可以一人一半，然后这个孩子的医药费或者其他的费用我不要求你承担，我自己还是自己承担。他答应的可好了，就在孩子90周岁生日那天，我给他打个电话，他答应的可好可好了，然后还答应说，我还跟他说，因为他态度那天特别好，我还跟他说，你作为一个男人，这孩子9岁多了，你从来没养他一天。因为是个男孩儿，我就说你应该就是每周陪孩子玩一下哈。对于一个男孩来讲，有一个男性的榜样其实很重要，他也答应的特别好。然后他孩子生日那天给孩子买一个篮球，跟孩子说他每周带孩子打一次篮球，然后就失联了。
就是到现到现在也不接电话了，也不露面了，也不给我打电话了，也不接我的电话。孩子用孩子的那个电话手表给他打，他也不接了。那孩子现在这个学习费用，我确实是也没法负担了，我能有什么办法能解决到这一部分费用呢？看完大概一年之后，他父母开始每个月拿1000块钱的那个现金到学校门口去看，因为他平时看不着孩子，他又不接又不送嘛，他就避着我们，等于是。然后他就每每个月找一天下午放学，然后他到学校门口给孩子一个1000块钱，然后他说这是你的生活费，六年了吧，都是他父母在给，他从来没给过一次。如果说这一一个月1000块钱的生活费对方已经给了，现在你要求说孩子的补习班的费用，我们平分这个事情是很难得到法院支持的。因为这个东西，它是需要双方先同意一起给孩子报这个补习班，然后比如说我们签个协议，我们共同来分担这个事情。这种情况下可以，但如果说他不同意给孩子报这个课外的补习班，你执意一个人要给孩子报这个补习班的话，这个费用它是在法律上是不支持他来分担的，就是孩子补习班或者其他的这些费用，我去嗯法院想办法是没有用的，没有用。对你要么你就换个思路吧，你给孩子买个学习。
机自己在家里学习也是可以的，因为补习班确实是太贵了。对我也想了各种办法，就我这种自我主张的这种学习费用啊，法院可能不支持，就是医疗费，比方说他是不是必须要支持啊？如果发生孩子实实在在发生的一些额外的这个医疗的费用，你要求对方去承担，这个是可以的。这个可以，那他就是到现在为止还在各个网络平台上在留我的手机号码，我还是在不停的接到这种短信啊电话啊什么的，我有什么办法能就是因为我问别人都跟我说，你拉黑，你把这个电话号码拉黑。我有一个办法，因为你看啊，我们平时用的这个手机号码可能关系到我们的银行卡，关系到我们的各种各样的这个需要收验证码的情况，对不对？那我这个号码呢，我不换，但是呢，我多给自己增加一个新的号码。这个号码我平时都飞行模式，平时我对吧，我就飞行模式，我不接电话，我给自己工作和生活，我再增加一个别的电话号码。这样的话，呃，我就再也不会收到那种骚扰短信啊什么的，因为我的前夫是不知道我的新号码的，我的新号码是不会告诉我的前夫，也不会告诉我的前公公婆婆，也不会告诉我这些其他的亲戚。我心。
号码就是工作用的，我换了一个新的号码，然后孩子的那个电话手表是有我两个号码，我希望他能找到我。他这样在对他在带孩子的时候偷看了孩子的电话手表，把我的另外一个号码记住了。然后我那个号码现在也开始受到这种电话骚扰。那我如果是我是你的话，我可能用我妈妈的名义再办一个电话号码，因为我没有教孩子说恨他这件事情。如果你不是那种假设啊，你不是那种没有销售的，不是那种嗯，就是非要跟陌生人联络的，你直接设置为所有你没有存的号码都打不进来就行。就是不是不光打不进来，还有短信息，它是可以发进来的，就不停的有事，因为有我的工作，涉及到一些和和外单位的联系，我是需要接到一个外单位电话的，不能说一个电话都不接的，我就特别痛苦。因为这个事情，你孩子已经9岁了，这个事情对会造成了非常非常大的伤害。因为我跟他是是同学，是中学同学，后来就发生这个他骗我的事情的时候，包括他父母啊，他的这个职务就是工作岗位啊什么的，我的中学同学，我们关系好的，回忆起来都说他父他父亲不是干那个那个工作的吗？就是他从初中给我们带来讲的话，就都是假的就是这么多年了，都是假的。他就是一个彻底彻头彻尾的骗子。我跟你讲，还有一件事情你必须要学会，虽然说你没有在孩子面前诋毁他的爸爸。
但你也没有必要在孩子面前去塑造一个虚假的形象，当你的孩子逐渐接纳他爸爸真实的样子就可以了。你没有必要说非得在孩子的生命当中塑造一个好的爸爸的形象，然后让孩子有一个好的榜样。这件事情是你从一开始就做错了的，因为所谓的榜样一定是他真实的，他身上有很多品质值得你的孩子去学习的才叫榜样。像你的这个情况，就不应该让孩子的爸爸再介入到孩子的生活当中去，就不应该让孩子的爸爸跟孩子走得太近，在孩子心目中去塑造一个榜样啊，这件事情，我们从一开始就不该做。是这个可能是我做的不好的地方，老觉得让他知道他爸爸爱他，其实他爸爸不爱他，我跟你讲啊，其实这件事情对于孩子来说，越是让孩子尽早的知道我爸爸不靠谱，尽早的知道这件事情对他的伤害越小。如果你在他心里种下一颗种子了，说爸爸很爱你，那将来的话，我说句难听点的话，他爸爸再问儿子借钱怎么办，儿子心里就有一种道德负担。儿子以后工作了，儿子以后有家庭了，儿子以后有收入了，他爸爸问儿子借钱怎么办？儿子心里就会有一种负担呀。我爸爸是爱我的呀，对吧？我爸爸也赔了我呀，那我不能眼见着我爸爸就见死不救啊。但反过来讲，如果孩子从小就接纳了我爸。
靠谱，我爸老欠钱，我爸害我妈害挺惨。我爸老跟跟他屁股后头那个老撒谎，他以后就不会，他以后不会有那种情感和道德上的纠结，不会说被他爸爸再去绑架。你说的对，所以就是在孩子除了这个1000块钱生活费的这个基础上，其实关于孩子的这个费用，或是就是法律上走法律途径来讲，是不可能得到其他支持的对吧？嗯，对额外的补课费用，额外的那种就是超出我们，超出我们正常的公立学校或者说学校要的这些费用。你额外的这些补课费用，你想要得到对方的那个一半的承担的话，这个嗯比较难。如果他初中上私立中学的那个学费会比较贵的话，这个法律支持吗？不支持就是除非说先获得他的同意，就是你俩商量着来可以，但你自己决定的，额外的，比如说私立学校的费用，额外的补课的费用，这个都支持不了。好的，谢谢啊，菲姐，嗯，不好，谢的，谢谢啊，嗯，再见，我觉得我刚才这段话不光适用于连麦的这个妹妹，也适用于现在直播间其他的当妈妈的这些姐妹。如果你的孩子的爸爸，他明确就是一个骗子，明确就是一个无赖，明确他就是一个对吧，他就是一个坏人。在这种情况下，你千万不要在孩子面前。
去塑造一个榜样，在孩子面前，去告诉孩子，爸爸还是爱你的，就这那的。其实某种程度上是增加了孩子的情感负担，当孩子对他的爸爸有期待。
他就会有痛苦，他就会有失落，他就会有被骗的那种伤心。当孩子对他爸爸没有期待，没有没有那种说期待着爸爸会在我过生日的时候会给我送礼物，期待着爸爸会在我学校毕业的时候来看我。他没有这样的期待的时候，他反而就不痛苦吧。我不知道我这么讲大家能不能接受，我经常跟大家讲说，我们一分为二的来看待她丈夫和父亲的这个角色，针对的是哪些人啊？针对的是虽然说她在情感上背叛了你，伤害了你，但是她对孩子是有感情的，她对孩子是有关心的，她对孩子也是有付出的。像这种情况下，我们可以一分为二的来看待他的身份。你虽然背叛了我，但是我不会阻止你和孩子的见面，不会阻止你去爱孩子，我觉得这个是没问题的。但如果说这个父亲本身他就是像刚才那个人啊，他本身就是从小就是个骗子，从小就是个无赖，从小就是一个就是做事情从来不计较后果的这么一个人的话，你没必要让他跟孩子接触啊。